Hi friends I'm late but I'm making this video quickly because I just
saw 1 comment that asked me 1 question and I thought it would be more
complicated to answer directly on video because it can help more
than one So the person was asking me,
she was telling me that she had been admitted and
that her visa was late to come out.
How do you do it in this situation?
If you have your admission to a university
for the beginning of the school year,
uh for the beginning of the fall school year for example,
and then your administrative procedures with an embassies,
i.e.
your face dyed as an assortment.
Say how you do it Because school is over,
how do you do it Are you losing your admission Are you losing everything Are you
going to start all over again at 0?
What you do in this kind of situation is 1 postponement of session 1 postponement
of session simply consists of contacting your university or your subject,
telling them,
I received 1 admission,
uh,
in your institution,
but considering the slow administrative procedures,
I haven't received my study permit yet,
I don't want to lose that admission can you postpone
my admission to the session next?
That is,
instead of starting everything back to 0 The institution will just put on the list
of people already admitted for the next session So you will have hum time To receive
your study permit and you will just start your hum your back to school in winter
For example if you have made 1 meal for the winter,
rescheduling in some universities is only possible once So if you have postponed
1 time and that in winter you still don't have your visa,
you can't do it 1/2 times.
You will simply have to redo 1 full admission for the fall start after
the fall start of the school year.
So that's really having to do with your university.
Now you don't lose everything.
If your visa is late in coming out,
you can do 1 session postponement and it's free.